vous reconnaissez être complètement
obsédé absolument oui complètement
absolument vous n'avez pas de raison
d'avoir honte ah j'ai absolument pas
à combien on fait ça à 3 4 ça dépend ça
fait longtemps que vous êtes un CD du
bois de Boulogne
maintenant oui est-ce que vous avez des
comment on dit des spécialités que vous
préférez
je ne suis pas assez fort pour faire le
milieu alors je fais souvent le point il
m'arrive le milieu des fois mais il faut
être
fortabilité le milieu alors le tir un
peu moins mais faut être très à droite
aussi bon bah écoutez on va voir en
pleine action un obsédé du bois de
Boulogne puisqu'on n'avez pas hésité à
agir dans la caméra donc c'est vraiment
que vous n'avez pas
voilà un obsédé du bois
dans ces coupables activités dans le 16e
arrondissement il y a en tout homme un
cochonnet qui somme